on sait que c'est intéressant comme
gominet hawass est certes un peu austère
un austère donc moi je suis loyal et des
techniques professionnelles j'ai pas on
pourrait utiliser les couleurs
l'aquarelle
beaucoup plus lemagnen peu plus
attrayant oui ou des photographes oui
alors il ya des circuits des circuits
qui vont être proposées dans la vie d
les cheminements de se sentir
la redondance
c'est des propositions et on peut se
retrouver sur ce plan qui est un plan
dans le
le style du plan de turcot devrait
arriver
pour koné
j'ai dessiné un peul cette pression là
il al avantage c'est qu'il est peut être
prise plus lisible qu'un véritable plan
c'est pas nous ont été plantés dans la
vie comme ça des lieux très pratique
d'après des stationnements d'autobus
c'est là où les gens attendent quelques
petites minutes les attend ils ont la
possibilité tout à coup de lire un texte
qui s'offrent à eux et qui raconte un
peu lui qui donne une leçon et ça n'est
pas fait pour les touristes quand elle
du père qui n'ont que urbaniste et qui
travaille pour la ville de nantes à ce
sujet propose des cheminements dans la
ville mais ça s'adresse aux habitants
ça s'adresse aux nantais bien sûr les
touristes pourront s'en servir mais on
s'aperçoit que les gens connaissent très
mal leurs vies qui le sous-estiment qui
n'en connaissent pas les
bien sûr ils connaissent certaines
choses
ils restent insensibles à l'autre c'est
un peu vrai hormis le passage pommeraye
le château où la cathédrale on est bien
souvent incapables de mesurer l'histoire
ou les petits à côté d'une si vieille
ville que ce soit l'espace théâtral de
la place graslin
le carrefour de la rue jean jacques
rousseau une multitude de détails à
découvrir par ces panneaux des panneaux
qui ne resteront pas à structure mortes
sont appelés à se transformer au fur et
à mesure pour présenter aux nantais un
maximum d'informations pas forcément
tournés vers le passé mais on n'est pas
du tout nostalgique non mais
positivement on veut que cette ville
vive on tient compte du patrimoine bien
sûr
s'agit pas de regret des choses on va
par creuser les canaux pourquoi ce
serait ridicule